joining me in the studio has promised a
minute ago Governor Rick Perry the great
state of Texas 47th governor he's
defended Texans conservative values
fought for principled solutions to tough
challenges and work to implement clear
vision for better skills I'm reading
this bio I'm not reading any more so I
but what I do know about him is we're in
Texas all the time and he and I just met
for the first time today but we've got a
lot of mutual friends and a lot of
mutual friends in Texas and he and our
governor here in the state of Tennessee
Governor Bill Haslam have managed to
make the state of Tennessee in the state
of Texas a--'s economy literally boom
while many other economies are
struggling around the nation welcome
governor good to have you it's good to
be here
I got it you got a good governor he gets
it about keeping the tax burden it's
light on job creators as you can and
having a regulatory climate that's fair
and predictable legal system and doesn't
allow for over suing an accountable
public schools basically translates into
a skilled workforce those are the four
things you get those four things right
and your economy will flourish so that's
the secret it's not rocket science I
mean and it will work anywhere I tell
people I say leave Morgan California I
know that's kind of hard
some people believe but it will mean you
got to have courageous men and women and
I'm talking about legislatures governors
etc that are willing to put those
policies into place because special
interest always want you to spend more
money and on this program of that
program in 2003 a good example of the
first time we had Republican leadership
in Texas since reconstruction so pretty
good spell Democrat control but in
January 2003 and we also faced a ten
billion dollar budget shortfall because
we'd had a technology bubble burst at
that particularly on one time and we had
some restrictions on the revenues coming
into the state and we had all run on the
concept that if we get elected we get
the privilege to lead the state that
we're going to treat our state budget
like we treat our personal budgets or
small business budgets and the left and
the Democrats basically said oh you if
you do that you'll destroy the state
nobody will move to the state you'll the
reputation of the state will
Ireland to the ground and we didn't buy
into that we believed the supply-side
economics it will art Laffer and Ronald
Reagan process would work and we put
that in place we cut ten billion dollars
out of our state budget and then wasn't
easy I mean don't get me wrong it was
some hard decisions but the result was
we came back in for our next legislative
session in January 2005 and we had an
eight billion dollar budget surplus mask
usin because we've talked about this a
lot around the coffee table over the
years those of us that are regular guys
wondering about those of you guys that
are politicians so you actually looked
at people ten billion dollars worth and
used the word no yes sir and got
reelected two more times yeah I mean
because there had to be people screamin
oh the editorial pages of some of the
papers were pretty brutal and obviously
those on the Left you know your
universities were going to go all to
heck in a hand basket the voter who's
used to getting something from the state
who's now not a programming more like
web program is gone how do they how do
they go on how they go along with this
because their grandmother that used to
get so-and-so or their uncle that used
to get so-and-so doesn't get it any well
you got to remember Texas is not what
you'd call a rich state when it comes to
these programs I mean we made decisions
long time ago that we weren't going to
have a lot of government-run handout
programs in the state so what people
found after a period of time was that
freedom really mattered that freedom
from over taxation from over-regulation
let's say you're a Hispanic in Texas and
that's one of the real growing groups in
the state of Texas and historically that
voted for Democrats but a young man who
in let's say 2006 dropped out of high
school as a 16 year old bought a used
pickup truck got married and his
economic future didn't look real bright
but because of policies that would put
in place in that state in particular on
the energy side of things and this young
man's case he got to dry a job driving a
truck in that Eagle Ford region down
south of San Antonio making over a
hundred thousand dollars a year and now
he's living in a two-bedroom excuse me a
two-bath three-bedroom house new house
they and his wife have two children
they're talking about where these kids
are going to go to college and I might
add his vote in Republican now because
he knows that the reason that his life
is better is because of policies the
Republicans put into place and and
that's our that's our not only our
challenge it's also our goal as we go
forward here and you know in possible
preparation of a 2016 presidential run
that we're able to have that
conversation with people from all strata
as if you will whether they're a young
Hispanic who's just getting started in
life or whether it's a blue-collar
Teamster Union those folks ought to look
at the Republican policies that are in a
place like Texas or Tennessee and say
you know what I that's how I want to
live I want to live free from over
taxation over regulation you let me keep
more of my money I'll make the best
decisions and that's what we've done in
Texas those four things we put into
place we got out of the way by the way
there's a job for that guy
becausebecause a government program but
because there wasn't a government
program Pam and you got out of the way
bingo and art Laffer is a buddy of mine
and he said he used to econ calls Ronald
Reagan the real president he said he
used to try to sit around tell the real
president the best thing you can do is
try to not do anything try to stay on
the way try to stay out of the way it
really is it's all right thing for
Washington to do and you think about it
it's a hard thing for politicians to do
yeah it is but I think Washington do I
think we've done it pretty good in Texas
I mean from December of oh seven through
December 14 you got to remember that's
the worst recession this country has
gone through since the Great Depression
during that period of time that seven
year period of time day Texas created
1.5 million net private-sector jobs the
rest of the country the 49 other states
lost 400,000 jobs during that period of
time
and the reason we were successful one
because we're dependent upon the oil and
gas industry it's because prior to that
we put these policies into place and you
saw the extraordinary diversification of
our economy whether it's manufacturing
that come in whether it was hi-tech
whether it was medical I mean our
economy is so diversified now that's the
reason that we grew and that's the
reason we were able to make it through
that recession better than any other
state and we can do the same thing for
this country but we got to have people
in Washington DC that trust the states
because if you'll allow the states to
compete if you'll block grant the the
the medical decisions back to the states
you block grant the transportation
decisions I trust bill Haslam and the
legislature and Ron Ramsey and those
guys making the decisions for Tennessee
a lot better than some bureaucrat in
Washington DC think about this this
whole concept of common core and and
that there's one size fits all for
educational curriculum well you know
that's nonsense
people know that's nonsense but all we
have a local school board exams up
exactly so the hard part's going to be
finding the courageous men and women
that are in the United States Congress
that are in the United States Senate
they say you know what we're going to
we're going to put this burden on the
states we're going to block grant these
dollars back to the states there'll be
some there there may be a state or to
that method up but the fact is that's
how our founding fathers saw it old
louis brandeis who was a Supreme Court
justice very liberal one I might add but
he respect the Constitution he said
states are the laboratories of democracy
he said they're supposed to go out there
and experiment and he said from time to
time one of them's going to mess up but
he said at least they haven't destroyed
the republic I fear that if Obamacare is
not replaced that we will in fact see
the loss of the Republic oh and rain on
those of us that run the businesses is
astronomical it is millions of dollars
from me without a doubt governor thank
you protect anytime thank you Dave
enjoy Tennessee while you're here we'll
be back off safe have a safe trip by the
way actually you're Tennessee from Texas
and we appreciate you
I'll show you when we're all stood next
to Sarah thank you god bless
Oh